♪ ♪
>> Emily: THE WHITE HOUSE
CORONA VIRUS TASK FORCE IS
COMING UP AND THERE’S BEEN SOME
ENCOURAGING NEWS THIS WEEK.
ONE KEY MODEL PART FORECASTING
FAR FEWER DEATHS FROM
CORONAVIRUS THAN EARLIER
ESTIMATES BUT WE STILL NEED TO
KEEP UP THE SOCIAL DISTANCING
ACROSS THE COUNTRY TO KEEP THAT
TREND GOING.
THE MEDIA IS NOT MAKING THE
SITUATION ANY BETTER WITH
ATTACKS LIKE THIS ON
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
>> TENS OF THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE
WILL DIE IN THE COUNTRY OR SOME
OF THEM HAVE ALREADY DIED AND
MORE WILL DIE BECAUSE OF
DONALD TRUMP’S INCOMPETENCE AND
LACK OF LEADERSHIP.
>> HERE WE HAVE A PRESIDENT WHO
IS EXPLOITING A NATIONAL CRISIS
TO MOVE FORWARD HIS OWN AGENDA,
IS ON THE REVENGE AND OWN PROFIT
PROFIT.
>> Emily: AND IT GETS WORSE.
WORSE.
NBC’S CHRIS HAYES PROMOTING A
CONSPIRACY THEORY THAT THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION INFLATED THE
DEATH TOLL PROJECTIONS OF THE
PRESIDENT COULD TAKE A "VICTORY
LACKLAP."
GREG, YOU ALWAYS FEEL SO
STRONGLY ABOUT THE MEDIA AND I
WANTED TO ASK YOU, IS THERE
ANYTHING THAT YOU THINK THE
MAINSTREAM MEDIA WILL HAVE AN
APPROPRIATE PERSPECTIVE ON?
>> Greg: I THINK, I COMPLETELY
UNDERSTAND THE POETICAL
POLITICS.
IT’S A TEAM SPORT THING, AND
LIKE SOME VIRUSES IT’S
INCURABLE.
THE ONLY THING THAT BOTHERS ME
IS THE MEDIA SO CLEARLY ON ONE
SIDE, I’D LIKE TO CHANGE THAT
BUT IT’S NEVER GOING TO HAPPEN.
ACOSTA ASKING WHETHER TRUMP HAD
INVESTMENTS IN HYDROXY, AS IF
TRUMP WOULD RISK HIS REELECTION,
HIS LEGACY FOR A COUPLE HUNDRED
DOLLARS IN STOCK, IT’S JUST.
EVEN MORE IS, IT’S NOT EVEN A
COST ORIGINAL.
HE STOLE THAT FROM THAT DON’T WE
DO WELL, MORNING JOE.
I THINK WE SHOULD TO CONTACT
TRACING ON REALLY DUMB IDEAS IN
THE MEDIA.
IDENTIFYING SOMEONE WHO’S BEEN
NEAR SOMEONE INFECTED WITH THE
DUMB IDEA AND THEN TRY TO TRACE
IT BACK.
IT STARTS WITH MSNBC, THEN MOVES
TO CNN AND GOES BACK TO NBC.
IF WE COULD STOP IT WE COULD
PREVENT MORE INFECTIONS.
ONE LAST POINT.
IF THIS PANDEMIC IS FAR LESS
THAN WHAT WE DICTATE IS GOING TO
CREATE A SWIRL OF UNPROVABLE
ARGUMENTS.
SO WE MIGHT AS WELL JUST GET
USED TO IT.
WE WILL HAVE ONE SIDE SAYING
IT’S ALL SOCIAL DISTANCING AND
ANOTHER ONE SAYING THAT FEAR WAS
OVERSOLD.
THE PROJECTIONS WERE RIDICULOUS
AND PEOPLE SAY THAT TRUMP SAVED
LIVES BY SHUTTING DOWN TRAVEL.
OTHERS WILL SAY HE PUT THE
ECONOMY BEFORE PEOPLE.
THESE THINGS ARE GOING TO GO ON
FOR THE REST OF YOUR LIFE.
YOU DON’T WANT TO GET SUCKED
INTO IT BECAUSE THEY ARE ALMOST
ALL UNPROVABLE.
>> Emily: DANA, I WANTED TO
PLAY A VIDEO FOR YOU AND GET
YOUR THOUGHTS ON IT.
THIS IS WHAT JAMES CARVILLE HAD
TO SAY, WHAT REPUBLICANS WILL DO
TO STAY IN POWER.
TAKE A LOOK AND I WILL GET YOUR
THOUGHTS.
>> WHAT I DO FEAR IS WHAT THEY
HAD IN WISCONSIN WHERE THEY TRY
TO MUCK WITH THE ELECTION, THAT
WAS ONE OF THE MOST AWFUL THINGS
THAT EVER SEEN IN MY LIFE.
JUST THE EXTENT THEY WOULD GO TO
TO HOLD ONTO POWER.
THEY WILL KILL PEOPLE TO STAY IN
POWER.
LITERALLY.
>> Dana: YOU WANT ME TO REACT
TO THAT.
SO THE WISCONSIN THING, I THINK
THAT CLEARLY THERE IS A LOT OF
CRITICISM THAT COULD BE THROWN
THAT WAY.
I DON’T KNOW -- WHY THEY
COULDN’T HAVE WORKED IT OUT, I
KNOW THERE WAS A PLANE TO BE HAD
ON BOTH SIDES.
THE REPUBLICANS AND THE
LEGISLATURE, THE GOVERNOR BEING
A DEMOCRAT AND SLOW TO MOVE, BUT
I THINK THE MOST RIDICULOUS
THING WAS YOU HAD THE SPEAKER OF
THE HOUSE FOR THE LEADER’S SHIP
OF THE STATE LEGISLATURE, A
REPUBLICAN, IN FULL ON
PROTECTIVE GEAR WITH A MASK
DOING AN INTERVIEW TELLING
EVERYBODY IN WISCONSIN THAT WAS
PERFECTLY SAFE TO GO OUTSIDE AND
VOTE.
THAT I THINK OPEN THEM OUT TO A
LOT OF CRITICISM.
AND IT’S NOT TOO EARLY TO START
THINKING ABOUT WHAT TO DO IN THE
FUTURE.
THERE ARE CRITICISMS ABOUT MALE
IN VOTING ALTHOUGH YOU HAVE
STATES LIKE UTAH THAT’S ALL MAIL
IN AND NO ONE SEEMS TO HAVE A
PROBLEM AND NO ONE QUESTIONS IT.
WE COULD HAVE THAT DEBATE.
THE ISSUE OF VOTER SUPPRESSION,
THE DEMOCRATS WILL TALK ABOUT
THAT A LOT BETWEEN NOW AND
NOVEMBER AND I THINK THE
REPUBLICANS HAVE TO HAVE A MUCH
BETTER ANSWER AS TO HOW THEY ARE
GOING TO TRY TO DEAL WITH IT.
IF I COULD SAY ONE THING ABOUT
THE QUESTION THAT ACOSTA POSTED
ABOUT THE FUNDING, IT REMINDED
ME THAT FOR EIGHT YEARS THE
MEDIA WOULD GO AFTER DICK CHENEY
OVER AND OVER AGAIN FOR
INVESTMENTS IN HALLIBURTON.
HE HAD NO INVESTMENTS IN
HALLIBURTON WHEN HE WAS A
VICE PRESIDENT.
HE WOULD NOT BE ABLE TO BENEFIT
AND IT DIDN’T MATTER HOW MANY
TIMES YOU EXPLAIN THIS TO TO
THEM IN A VERY LOGICAL WAY, THE
MEDIA JUST DIDN’T CARE.
THEY JUST TRIED TO CONTINUE TO
PUMMEL SOMEBODY.
BUT IF I COULD BE AS A SPORTS
ANALOGY, THIS ONE AT $450, IF
THAT’S THE INVESTMENT, THAT’S
WHAT YOU CALL A SWING AND A
MISS.
>> Emily: JESSE, ABC PUBLISHED
A DAMAGING REPORT ON
PRESIDENT TRUMP’S REACTION TO
THIS AND I’M MILITARY OFFICIAL
REFUTED IT AND REFUSED TO ISSUE
A CORRECTION.
BUT WE EVER SEE IS SOME TYPE OF
ACKNOWLEDGMENT OF THE
RESPONSIBILITY THAT THEY HAD IN
SHAPING THAT NARRATIVE?
>> Jesse: PROBABLY NOT.
YOU DIDN’T SEE IT WITH RUSSIA
AND I DON’T KNOW WHY YOU WOULD
SEE WITH THIS.
IF WE HAD TODAY’S MEDIA DURING
WORLD WAR II, THEY WOULD BLAME
FDR OR PEARL HARBOR INSTEAD OF
THE JAPANESE.
IT WOULD PROBABLY BLAME THE
HOUSE REPUBLICANS AT THE TIME.
BUT YOU SEE MY POINT, THIS IS
CHINA’S DEAL.
CHINA LIES.
THE W.H.O. BOTCH THIS.
THE VIRUS, MOTHER EARTH IS
KILLING PEOPLE, NOT THE
PRESIDENT.
THERE’S STILL SO MUCH WE DON’T
KNOW ABOUT THIS VIRUS.
THIS IS AN INVISIBLE AND COMIC
ENEMY.
WE SHUT DOWN THE ENTIRE U.S.
ECONOMY, THAT WASN’T AGGRESSIVE
ENOUGH?
THEY CRITICIZE THE PRESIDENT FOR
ACTING TOO LATE OR NOT LISTENING
TO THE SCIENTISTS.
SHOW ME IN FEBRUARY WERE
DR. FAUCI AND DR. BIRX SAID WE
ALL NEED TO SHELTER IN PLACE.
WE CAN’T FIND IT BECAUSE IT DOES
NOT HAPPEN.
DO YOU KNOW HOW MANY DEATHS
THERE WERE IN THIS COUNTRY ON
MARCH 1ST?
ONE.
SHOW ME ONE PUNDIT THAT SPOKE TO
THE COUNTRY ON THE NEED TO
SHELTER IN PLACE.
IF YOU CAN FIND THAT PERSON I
WILL BUY THEM A ROUND OF DRINKS.
BUT IT DIDN’T HAPPEN, THEY WERE
OBSESSED WITH MIKE BLOOMBERG AT
THIS TIME.
TO GREG’S POINT, YOU CAN PLAY
WITH THESE MODELS AND
PROJECTIONS HOWEVER WAY YOU
WANT.
YOU COULD SAY TRUMP SAVED THE
LIVES, YOU COULD SAY MITIGATION
WORKS, YOU CAN SAY THE MODELS
WERE WRONG OR THE MODELS WERE
UPDATED WHEN NEW INFORMATION WAS
PUT INTO IT.
LOOK AT THE CLIMATE CHANGE
MODELS.
ALL OF THEM HAVE BEEN WRONG AND
YET PEOPLE ARE OBSESSED WITH THE
CLIMATE CHANGE MODELS.
I COULD PLAY THIS GAME ALL DAY.
I COULD SAY BARACK OBAMA DID
NOTHING WHILE THE OPIOID
EPIDEMIC COST 200,000 AMERICAN
LIVES AND THAT’S ON HIM.
I COULD SAY THAT BUT I WON’T
BECAUSE I’M A VERY CLASSY GUY.
>> Emily: [LAUGHS]
ALL RIGHT.
JUAN, WHAT ARE YOUR THOUGHTS ON
ANYTHING YOU LIKE FROM WHATEVER
EVERYONE SAID IT?
>> Juan: EMILY, LET ME GO BACK
TO THIS BUSINESS ABOUT WHAT
HAPPENED IN WISCONSIN.
YOU KNOW, I JUST THOUGHT THAT
WAS A HUGE FLAW, I THINK IT WAS
AN EMBARRASSMENT FOR US AS
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
I DON’T THINK PEOPLE SHOULD HAVE
TO CHOOSE BETWEEN STAYING
HEALTHY AND PARTICIPATING IN AN
ELECTION.
I THOUGHT IT WAS WRONG AND EVEN
WHEN THERE WERE QUESTIONS ABOUT
MALE IN VOTING TO THE PRESIDENT
YESTERDAY, THE PRESIDENT SAID
OH, NO.
IT’S TERRIBLE AND YOU COULD SEE
IT ALL IN FRONT.
AND THEN THEY SAID,
MR. PRESIDENT YOU VOTED BY MAIL
AT THE LAST ELECTION IN FLORIDA
AND HE SAID YES, THAT’S TRUE.
TO ME IT’S ABOUT VOTER
SUPPRESSION.
WE WILL COME BACK TO THAT TOPIC.
FOR THE MEDIA, I WOULD PUT IT IN
THE CATEGORY OF NOT HELPING US
TO MOVE FORWARD, NOT HELPING US
TO PROGRESS AND GET OUT OF THE
SITUATION.
THIS THING IS SO SERIOUS I WOULD
RATHER NOT GET HOOKED UP IN
THOSE KIND OF TRIVIAL
FINGER-POINTING, BACKBITING AT
BACKSTABBING.
I WILL SAY THAT A NONPARTISAN
BASIS, THE FACT IS THAT WE AS A
COUNTRY WERE SLOW TO RESPOND IS
SPECIFIC.
THE PRESIDENT WHEN HE WAS
DOWNPLAYING THE SERIOUSNESS OF
IT, I THINK THE ADMINISTRATION
WAS SLOW TO RESPOND.
BUT LET’S LEAVE IT THERE AND NOW
TRY TO PICK UP PACE AND DO THE
THINGS THAT ARE NECESSARY TO GET
US IN THE RIGHT PLACE BECAUSE I
THINK -- THERE’S NO NEED FOR US
TO GET INVOLVED IN HARSH
CONSPIRACY THEORIES THAT DON’T
ACTUALLY LEAD US IN A MORE
PRODUCTIVE PLACE.
>> Greg: ONE POINT THOUGH, HE
DID SHUT DOWN TRAVEL THREE DAYS
AFTER IT WAS RAISED.
SO I MEAN MAYBE YOU COULD HAVE
DONE AT THE SAME DAY.
AND HE GOT CRITICIZED.
HE WAS CALLED RACIST.
>> Juan: LESSON.
IN FACT, PEOPLE WHO WERE STILL
COMING IN -- I THINK MORE THAN
HALF MILLION PEOPLE STILL CAME
FROM CHINA BECAUSE YOU HAD
AMERICANS COMING BACK FROM THAT
AREA AND YOU HAD PEOPLE COMING
FROM ITALY.
YOU HAD PEOPLE COMING FROM
GERMANY AND FROM BRITAIN.
SO LET’S ARGUE ABOUT THE
EFFECTIVENESS IN ANOTHER WAY.
I’M JUST SAYING, WE AS A COUNTRY
WERE SLOW TO RESPOND.
LET’S FOCUS NOW ON WHAT WE CAN
DO BECAUSE RIGHT NOW EVEN AS WE
REOPEN BUSINESSES, WHAT WE ARE
GOING TO SEE IS THAT PEOPLE ARE
SLOW TO GET BACK TO THE
RESTAURANTS AND SLOW TO GET BACK
ON AN AIRPLANE, SLOW TO GET BACK